Now mr. Mayor archie meek worked on the
sydney harbour bridge when he was only
a young fellow do you remember those years.
Do you when you were first taken on can
you remember being given a job
i can remember being given
a job and i worked for dave irvine which
foreman at the time and i went with the
riveters on the hydraulic
riveting machines they were
a big horse shoe type and the rivet
risqué used instead of hammer down like
a rattler machine. How
many were you are you in
a gang of four the hydraulic riveting.
Oh they will be for assistance in
a ball and i have what it
each of you do. That's
a first one to one of them heated the
rivets and the other one right group the
gantry another on his shop
bought out the two used one pass
a revit and the other used to push
the big pull the big hoses had
a held up of course opposite the
boiler maker. And he didn't need
a car he didn't need
a catcher and that job. You know we were
on ground level the reverse was thrown
underneath the job on the ground all
dirt floor. And then the hold up
picked it up put it in the
hole and so now we had
a boy put it in the house. We still
have big heavy rivets because the
plates were about an inch thick. And
they were sometimes six and eight
cly. So the rivers have to be about
eight or nine inches long and
a boy you know about seventeen. Yes.
At the use tongs in one hand and
a seven pound hammer now that hammer i
mean to the horse and they did you do any
any pneumatic riveting after that.
I know i didn't work with them.
But most of the jobs we did
was for the big big columns
you know our shoes and everything and they
went from our shop up to the heavy shop
and they were all put together and build
like boxes big box girders that's where
they used to handle everything. And how
long did you work there in the workshop. I
worked there for about three
years. How it was sort of
a job was it you get good money. At
that time was start of the depression
or money was good that time and because
we never thought we got enough because we
had to work very hard at the amount of the
working conditions in the workshops or
our working conditions was continuous all
the time and i don't mean the conditions
i mean the nature of the job we would go
from one job to another while we're away
on one job they were turning the other
one over. So who you. We never stopped.
There was hard work along for lunch
a. Well we had it. We were in shift
work. We were going from seven or three
one shift with about half an hour break
and we were going from free to eleven on
another shift to member dave
avandia the foreman. I remembered
a bourbon well yes. But the hard
man was well dave was fair.
He was one of the boys he well liked
and whatever they said went you know.
Do you member any union
meetings in the shop. There was
a lot of union meetings. But b and yari
most of the meetings there were with
a boilermakers
a c and we were only the boys. You didn't
go up on the arch at all to yourself.
If we had time at lunch time we used to
try and run up there. But it was also
letters and. It took
a long while to get up there. Did you do
you remember any any amusing things that
happened while you were
in there. Not very many
. But an accident so many many hard things
that. That strike you made now either
a lot of berms and everything but it was
a well-conducted shop. Everything
went along like on assembly line and
. The job was hard and you still
lose plenty of sweat but it was
no well-conducted well organized. What
happened to you after you finished up what
you did you finish up first. I finished
about 1931 after they just finished the
roadway and. I left there and
after that i worked around casual picking
up work wherever i could until about
an hour and
a thirty six. And i went to new guinea where
they were building gold regions cedar
they vervain up there to do i miss dave
ever and then he had just left and he went
back to cockatoo. So i worked up there
for about three years and i came back i
worked
a cockatoo that was just about the starting
of the war. We ever on the dole where i
was on the dole. Yes i was on the dole
for about five years after the harbour
bridge. You know work at
all. Well we're still
a little bit of weak relief work. I was
married at the time. And i used to get two
weeks out of every five work. So
what was sort of work. Was it.
It was all around road work. Did you get
paid for that it is just pay you were the
girl who we got paid. We're going to weekly
pay at that time for one week was about
£3 £3 ten. How did that compare with what
you were paid at the workshops are no
comparison at all but we only got
that those two weeks in five weeks.
And then you won coupons in the weeks where
you know that was once your work and
you don't get coupons. So what did you get
then when once you were here just got
nothing else other than what the working
got material £3 10s about £7 for five
weeks. That's pretty hard. Honey. Least you
had some cash in your pocket to pay the
rent. Whereas if you were on coupons
you had nothing to pay the rent. It's
a fact that. Did you have any children.
You're married barrett i. Well halfway
through that five year period
that i was on the dow. We had
a daughter hess how do
you get by and he's in
a harder as well as well on the five weeks
i was looking for work and i used to
pick up a couple of hours
round the shipyards is
a bit of painting and talking and
such but there was no no work in
a metal trade at all. I work in the metal
trade we used to go down to mulch dark
and terrible i'm there seven o'clock of
a morning. Bed be anything from 500
to 800 people waiting for might be
five or six jobs and then i was home have
a little ange out again for the afternoon
picking up somewhere else. Towing the
line you know on. And all the metal work
jobs which is the same as that i know the
wharfies jobs were like that was the metal
work jobs like that all the way through
. Yes better work was all the way through
the same the only jobs as i say on at
that time was the harbour bridge when the
harbour bridge finished for the metal
trades. Who was just nothing about shipping
ships weren't being built. They didn't
start building ships until or did you get
married. Well while you were working at
the bridge. Yes yes i got married because
i just finished the bridge when i got
married. Did you might give
your clock and. I think as
a few of them got who got married during
the building of the bridge. So they got to
give them the clock or
a subscription was taken out for them but
if you left. Well that was different that
you can remember. Any other sort of
incidents that stick out in your mind while
you were working there. You know.
Things were hard as i said before
when you was
a boy and working there. You was under
the control of the boilermaker and
it was
a hard job and i all hard men and
sometimes. If you were putting
a rivet in the hole and you hit it and you
hit didn't hit it square. The rebel bend
and have to come out and it was stop and
production. And the boilermakers start
racing on you and you'd roust back
and actually in a clip of a year or
a kick in the pants and did you have to
make the tea as well now we didn't have to
make the tea. Was there any smoke i do
you member. I don't think there was
a cut. Remember. Do you ma'am. Where did
you live that you member going to work. I
went to work. I lived in balmain at the
time and i live down there right down
a birch grove way. I separate work
from walk from birch grove down
to the moat stock wharf and catch
a ferry across to the workshops
that is where luna park is down
but coming home. I come home here
first on day shift the same way back
to march street and walk home. If i was on
afternoon shift. I could only go to work
. In our afternoon i start
to catch a bus catch
a ferry to secular quay and right round to
a birch square with
a tram which are about three quarters of
an hour. So knocking off at eleven o'clock
. You know about one o'clock. If you're
lucky and boys are on the afternoon shift
to boys shortly after shift
to yes we've made it
a long day and. It was three o'clock till
eleven o'clock you shift. But to get
there at three o'clock you definitely would
hope to accra. That if you as well as
as
a matter of whether you had the money if
you if you're fair. You didn't indulge in
the crown and anchor of the lunchtime with
the other side. Charlie rangel me ever
losing his money on the on the the crown
and anchor and having the scale of on the
trail. A lot of them did but i never found
the money so proud of all that by it.
Do you. Well course you weren't married
but nonetheless your parents weren't
exactly you father did he did he have
work at that time or not. My father
he worked on the harbour bridge. But on
the approaches. He worked on the north
sydney sorrowed more until
it came to the pilings
and he left there and went to the shipyards
pretty he was there or way before the
bridge the arch work was started and was
he finished up when the artwork started.
He was a yes it finished up at the
harbour bridge but he'd been working to
a shipyard. So he still had work
harder did. Yes. How did it go after
that after the bridge was finished was
a did he still have work. You know i thought
i had to go into state. He went down
to work on the murray bridge between the
murray bridge down there. He was down
there for about three or four years. Well
as you were trying to make ends meet.
Round sydney. That's right. They weren't
easy terms so they you know in out
. Time that time were very hard to
see the depression started about
1928 the depression started with
the timber workers timber work
started. And now timber supplied all
a housing finished they couldn't tell how
has it couldn't put roofs on it couldn't
read floors in so all the
housing finished. So that left
a shortage in the building industry for
a start. Yes.
What do you what do you think about the
proposal to add lanes to the bridge now i
don't think it would be a
good idea. I think there is
a nuff traffic going over it now. Not
the bridge couldn't hold the traffic.
But where were the traffic go where are
you going to cross the bridge who still
have to go on the existent roadways. I think
the bridge should go down further down
the harbour george the heads.
What's your thoughts now about the
bridge. Having worked on it and fifty years
later. Do you work at what he what do
you think of now looking back at it. I
think it'll be there another fifty years
easy. Year ever having to be well made.
Remember everything being accurate.
Everything was accurate where they
are building up all be the girders
all the holes were drilled they weren't
punched or anything they were all assembled
and drilled in the position. So all
the holes were clear clean. They were
pout and
a pin and an open how so. The plates
couldn't move and the holes were always hey
was clean the rivets were going in them
would fill up and there'd be no movement in
them plates. Have you seen jobs that
was good. Since i've never seen
a job organized i have
a bridge. What do you attribute that to
the doorman long of the public works
a world. Well dorm along first because
they had experience and build
a bridge building. But we had the
experience here but nearly all the
fellows that worked on my harbor bridge
came from the old country. They were
scotchman they were high richmond you
name it they were there and they all had
experience before they came over and not
many of them were brought over by doormen
long where they now
a lot of them came over. When australia
was being settled there was the oil
companies they came over here because there
was work building the big storage tanks
and everything and ship building was
booming at the start and they had
a slump and then all that labour was ready
to go on the harbour bridge. Do you
remember the bosses in the workshop do you
remember who was in charge of the worker
. I i know their immediate
boss was david on about him.
There was jim martin. I'm
not sure the other bosses
remember alf muttered. Yes i remember our
mothers. But what did he wear what sort
of clothes he wear or couldn't hurt. I
just ask because. Because jack grew once
said that he wore. The pommy cap as uniform
of a blue serge suit knitted tie and
a bowler hat. You don't remember.
Did you ever see and it's around
the place. Mr. Ennis
yeah. And what about dr.
Redfield ever see him around the block to
bradford yes you came about. Did you know
any of the inspectors around the workshop
i mean by sight. You didn't have
anything to do with them and
that's really the book and then as
a boy. You didn't serve your turn
to do you were you were working as
a worker. Yeah and work so you didn't have
to go to tech or anything like i think
at all. I just laborers
you did you later on do
a take on ball i'm making now but
i work with the boilermaker since
i went to new guinea
a 1936 constructing gold rages
and i went from there. Onto
the gold regime as one of the crew and
i was winching up there for. Puli gold
region. Did you work with laurie short
over. My work with larry shorted cockatoo
island and laurie short he was
a rabbit heating at the time and i was
a hold wrap. With the riverdance. They
didn't work. Any other jobs just that
one had got to ireland
before the harbour bridge
and now i mean after the highbridge
british i went to cockatoo
a casual work paid and asking did you ever
work with the. One of the coeur family
the governor-general's family. When
i come back from new guinea to be
where the war was on nineteen thirty
nine forty. I worked over cockatoo
island. One of my first bosses
was curly her curly hair was
a father of the governor george girls.
There's a quite
a number of people tell me they work with
him so. Well i can you think of anything
else that stands out in my
andrea the harbor bridge. Well
thank you very much to make.